Your summer starts now with Memorial Day deals at the Home Depot. It's time to fire up summer cookouts with the next grill, four-burner gas grill, on special buy for only $199. And entertain all season with the Hampton Bay West Grove's seven-piece outdoor dining set for only $49. This Memorial Day get low prices guaranteed at the Home Depot. While supplies last, price invalid May 14th or May 27th, U.S. only exclusions apply. See Home Depot.com slash price match for details.
您在全国家得宝（Home Depot）购买阵亡将士纪念日特惠商品，即可开启夏日美好时光。
Having good friends is key to kids' mental health and well-being, just as it is for adults. But it isn't always easy to navigate the complicated social dynamics of elementary, middle, or high school. Today we're going to talk with an expert on kids' friendships about how children make and keep friends and how parents can help support them as they do. So when do kids start to form real friendships? How does their understanding of friendship evolve as they grow from young children, to teens. Do all kids need a best friend? What do you do if your child is being bullied or excluded by a peer group? What if your kid is the one doing the excluding? What happens when your child
拥有好朋友对于孩子的心理健康和福祉至关重要，正如成年人一样。
has a friend you don't like or who doesn't treat them well? And how do kids navigate arguments with friends and even the inevitable friendship breakup? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. My guest today is Dr. Eileen Kennedy Moore, a clinical psychologist and author based in Princeton, New Jersey. She's written many books for children and parents about friendship, including growing friendships, a kid's guide to making and keeping friends, and kid confidence, help your child make friends, build confidence, and develop real self-esteem. She's also the creator of the podcast Kids Ask Dr. Friendtastic, where she answers questions directly from children about making and keeping friends,
不仅如此，他们对友谊的理解随着他们从幼儿成长为青少年而不断演变。
offering gentle, practical, and research-based advice on all kinds of friendship issues. Dr. Kennedy Moore has been featured in major print radio and TV outlets, including the New York Times, The Washington Post, and CNN. N.com. Dr. Kennedy Moore, thank you for joining me today. My pleasure, Kim. I'm delighted to be here. At what age do kids start forming real friendships, not just playing with the toddler who happens to be next to them in the sandbox? And how does their understanding of friendship change as they get older? Well, you're absolutely right. There is a developmental sequence in children's friendships. And at the toddler ages, we have that love the one you're with stage where they're just playing whoever's around. And then they expand to what I call the I want it my way stage. And this is for
好吧，你说得对。
ages about three to six where they have very limited ability to see someone else's perspective. And they assume that kids, other children see things exactly the way they do. So when another kid wants something else, it kind of blows their mind. Then we move into from seven to 12, the two-way fair-weather cooperation, which I call the by-the-rules kind of friendship. And here, kids have more of an idea of reciprocity, but they're very strict in how they do it. It's very much quid pro quo. If I do something nice for you, you'd better do something nice for me or everything falls apart. They tend to be very judgmental of both themselves and others.
这也是我们看到许多秘密俱乐部的年龄，对吧？
This is also the age where we see a lot of those secret clubs, where, right? They're talking forever about who's in and who's out and what the rules are in the club never actually does anything. A friend of mine said that her son at this stage was in a band, and they would talk about, you know, whose role everybody was playing, but none of them played an instrument. Perfect. Right. And then when we get from about age 12 up, we have those more mature friendships where it's through thick or thin.
我的一位朋友说，她的儿子在这个阶段加入了一个乐队，他们会讨论，你知道的，每个人都在扮演什么角色，但他们中没有人会演奏乐器。
but and they put a high value on closeness with friends. They can accept and even appreciate differences between themselves and other friends, and they're not quite as possessive as the earlier stages. So this is more like what we adults would think of as a friendship. At an earlier age, if a friend has another friend, they feel deeply betrayed. But once they move into the teen years, they understand that, Yeah, we can have multiple friends. How did you decide to focus on children's friendship as a subject for your books and your podcast?
你在写书和播客时，是怎么决定把儿童友谊作为主题的？
What got you interested in this area? Well, you could say it came from a personal place because when my family was growing up, we moved about every three years. So I became an expert at making friends at a very young age, kind of because I had to. And then as an adult, I studied the research about children's friendships. And I'm a clinical psychologist. So in my practice, I hear every day, every week about the concerns that children have about their friendships. Getting along with other people is hard. We adults haven't managed world peace or even perfect marriages.
是什么让你对这个领域感兴趣的？
So it's understandable that kids would also struggle in their relationships. But what the research tells us is that friendship is kind of the answer to everything. If you want a child to feel happier, help them make friends. if you want them to cope better with stress, fronts. If you want them to be more engaged with school, less likely to be bullied, friends. So we really do want to do what we can to support children's friendships. So speaking of that support, what can parents do that will help their children make friends that will back them up and give them the knowledge and the wherewithal to go out in the world and, you know, buddy up? Right.
如果你想让一个孩子感到更快乐，就帮他们交朋友。
You know, Kim, a lot of times in my practice, I see parents who feel very helpless when their kid is having a friendship rough spot. And it's like, well, I can't make friends for them. And that's true. But there are a lot of things that we as parents or as people who care about kids can do to support and nurture their friendships. What fuels that development of children's friendships from the love the one you're with friendships of the toddler years to the more intimate and lasting years of the teen years. is an increasing ability to understand someone else's perspective. So that's something that we adults can help with a lot. When we talk through a situation with them, we always want to start with empathy because our children need that understanding and that sense of being held and supported. But then we can help them to imagine the other child's perspective.
你觉得他当时有什么感受？
How do you think he felt when that happened? Why do you think she did that? And this is kind of expanding their awareness, developing their theory of mind. We can also talk about feelings as they come up in daily life or as we see it in a movie or a story. And don't do it so much that you ruin the story. But we can talk about, why do you think they did that? Or, ooh, how do you think you reacted there?
无论我们看到什么，都要帮助他们意识到这个丰富的内心世界。
Or, gosh, she seemed really excited about that. Whatever we see and help them to be aware of this whole inner world. There's research that when parents talk more about feelings, kids become better able to understand another person's perspective. Another thing we can do is place a high value on friendship. Let them see us making time. I know you're busy, so am I. We're all busy. But make time for those friendships.
我知道你很忙，我也是，我们都很忙。
Let your child see you going out of your way to get together with friends, to do kind things for your neighbors, to put a priority on relationships. And probably the single best thing we as parents can do for our kids to support their friendships is to help them have those one-on-one playdates. That's what really deepens the friendships, those one-on-one get-togethers. Now, in my practice, a lot of times kids will push back and say, oh, I don't really know the kid that well. That's okay. If you've had fun with them once, that's enough. You can invite them over.
现在，在我的实践中，孩子们很多时候会抗拒并说，哦，我其实不是很了解那个孩子。
So speaking of inviting them over in play dates, how has some? social media changed that behavior? Are kids still having play dates? Or would they rather text and talk on their phones? Well, I don't even mean talk on their phones. They don't use their phones to talk. They're only, they're not talking on their phones. They're, they kind of have an version to do that. It's, it's really texting or messaging through one of the apps. that's what research tells us is that social media in general supports and supplements children's real life friendships and for most kids that that's what they do of course there are cases where they're just spending all their time on that or they have it brings them down but it
所以社交媒体在多大程度上改变了这种行为？
can't substitute for that in person getting together. Inviting somebody over sends a powerful message that, hey, I like you enough to spend time with you outside of when we have to be together. So it really is a lovely thing. And even if the person says, no, you've still done that signaling that you are open to friendship. Often, I find that an activity-based get-together is good because an activity-based get-together allows the activity to pass over any of the awkwardness because kids know what to do. Often at the beginning of a play date, there's that awkward moment where one kid says to the other kid, what do you want to do? And the other kid says, I don't know, what do you want to do?
把某人请到家里来会传递一个强有力的信息，那就是，嘿，除了我们必须聚在一起的时间之外，我挺喜欢你，愿意花时间跟你在一起。
Right. So we can get past that if you prep your kid beforehand. So have them think of two things that they might want to do with a friend. And then when the friend arrives, you greet the friend and say, would you like to do A or B? And that allows the friend to get to playing together as quickly as possible. And that's what research says, shows whether they're likely to become closer friends, is how much time do they spend playing together? We also want to emphasize to our child that you are the host. So it's your job to make sure your guest has a good time.
所以如果我们提前对孩子进行指导，我们就可以克服这一点。
And how can you do that? So notice if the guest gets a little bored or gets frustrated, and that's a good time to suggest two more activities. Now, how does a parent's role change as the child gets older? What happens when you're dealing with, you know, a tween, an early teenage kid who is saying, Mom, I don't want to talk about this with you. How can you still help these children? Usually when children resist talking about friendship issues is because they're afraid they're going to get lectured and scolded, right?
当你在和一个正在经历青春期前期、刚进入青春期的孩子打交道时，他们会说，妈妈，我不想跟你谈这个，这时会发生什么？
So be very, very careful about that. Never criticize your child in front of other kids. There's actually studies that shows that that really hurts your child's social standing with their peers. And we want to ask questions more than telling answers. When we're teaching our kids math, we don't say four. The answer is four, right? We take, well, where's the numerator? Where's the denominator?
所以在这方面要非常非常小心。
And we guide them through that. This is the same thing with learning about getting along with peers. Start with empathy because they need you on your side. And pick your moment. Like when the child is really upset, that is not the time to say, see, didn't I tell you if you kept on like that, you were going to end up like this. So not a good idea. We have to be first on their side.
我们必须首先站在他们这一边。
And then we can ask questions. The older the kid is, the more important it is to ask questions rather than give answers. So you might say, so what do you think? you might do? Or how do you think she would react if you did that? And help them to think it through rather than respond impulsively. Let's talk about best friends. You wrote a piece for psychology today, the column that you write for that outlet about whether kids need a best friend. What's your take? Is it important for kids to have a bestie or is it okay to have multiple friendships that just aren't that close.
你对这件事有什么看法？
You know, every now and then in the popular literature, I see articles about, oh, kids shouldn't have best friends because, I don't know, I guess it's exclusive because then they might break up, which is true. But to me, having a best friend is a little bit like falling in love. So we parents and adults, we don't get to control that for our children. That's theirs. There are very few ways that children actually have. autonomy, but this is one of them in the relationships that they choose. So about a third to a half
你知道，在通俗读物中，我偶尔会看到一些关于“哦，孩子们不该有最好的朋友”的文章，因为，我不知道，我猜这是因为具有排他性，因为他们后来可能会绝交，这确实是真的。
of kids have best friends at any point. There are payoffs to having a best friend in terms of how kids feel and their happiness and sense of belonging. So it can be good. But of course, we know that there are different friendship qualities. So a best friend who is getting our kid in trouble? Maybe not so good. Right? And there's also research showing that the peer group can have a negative negative influence on our kids. So we want to help our children to make good choices about whom they decide to be friends with. So we can ask them questions like, how do you feel when you're with them? Or do you feel like you can be yourself with them or do you feel like you have to kind of fake it or or hide things from them.
随着他们和他们在一起时，你觉得自己能做自己吗，还是觉得你必须伪装自己或向他们隐瞒事情？
Do you feel like these friends bring out the best in you and guide them towards thinking it through? The one-on-one playdates can deepen the friendships, spending time together. Friendships take time. I read one study, and I never saw the original study, so I don't know how true this is, but it was saying that for adult friendships, it takes 30 hours to make a casual friend,
我读过一项研究，虽然我从未看过原研究，所以我不知道这有多真实，但它说对于成年人的友谊，培养一个泛泛之交需要30个小时，
60 hours to make a close friend and 90 hours to make an intimate front. Isn't that amazing? So again, I can't vouch for how accurate those numbers are. But the point is, it takes time to build that intimacy. So a moment ago you talked about maybe your kid has a best friend who's getting them in trouble. Isn't a child you wish your kid were associating with. What can you as a parent do when you see your kid is with somebody who's just not a good influence or maybe isn't treating your kid very nicely. Right. Sometimes kids stick to a not so good friend because they feel like they don't have any other
有时候，孩子们会死守着一个不太好的朋友，因为他们觉得自己没有其他选择了。
options. So we can help our kid recognize how they feel when they're with that friend. You know, just raise the questions without saying, dump that kid. As tempting as it is to say, you're not allowed to play with them. Be careful because you can. have a Romeo and Julia effect, right, that they suddenly seem more attractive. And if your kid doesn't have any options, they may feel afloat. Also, they may go into school and say, my mom says, I'm not allowed to play with you.
所以我觉得最好的选择是试着为其他可能的友谊添柴加火，让你的孩子体验一下更轻松、更友善的友谊，
That's not so good. So I think the best option is to try to fan the flames on other possible friendships and let your child experience the difference between an easier friendship, a kinder friendship. and this one that's more problematic. You may want to help your child get involved in activities. Kids make friends by doing fun things together. So what is it that your child is interested in or might be interested in that they could do with other people? And that could be a way to find people, find their tribe, find ones that they could relate to and connect with.
当友谊走到尽头时，你该如何帮助你的孩子度过与曾经的朋友绝交的难关，尤其是当你进入中学，每个人都分道扬镳的时候？
What about when friendships end? How do you help your child through a breakup with somebody who had been a friend, and especially when you get to middle school and everybody goes off in different directions? How do you support your child through that? Oh, it's hard, isn't it? And research tells us that among first graders, about half of friendships don't make it from September to June. And among fourth and eighth graders, one quarter of friendships don't last. So this is very, very common.
孩子们，从定义上讲，缺乏看待事物的宏观视角，对吧？
But children, by definition, lack perspective, right? They just haven't been around that long and they haven't seen that much of the world. So the anguish that they're feeling right now feels like a forever thing. Like they're always going to feel this sad. There are a couple of ideas here. One is we want to keep the door. If it was a good friendship before, we want to keep the door open to that reconnecting with that friend. So no slash and burn as things are going about.
我们成年人喜欢让孩子们把一切都说清楚。
Don't diss the other friend to everybody else at school. And we adults like the idea of kids always talking everything out. But what research tells us is that that doesn't become, negotiation and compromise doesn't become the main way that children resolve conflicts until age 19. Before then, they either insist and give in or they separate for a little bit and then come back together and just be nice to each other and they kind of step over the conflict. And that's also very important because one of the basic friendship skills is being able to forgive a friend for those unavoidable mistakes that they make and that we're going to make also. So when a child is going through a friendship breakup, and this can be as bad as a romantic breakup for an adult, like the pain is real, we want to empathize with them. Extra time with family can be a good consolation that, yes, you're still wanted, you're still loved, you still belong.
如果曾经是一段美好的友谊，
That can be very, very helpful. But we also might want to create opportunities for the. to make other friends and just leave the door open that maybe at a later point they can reconnect. I worked with a kid once where he and another boy were best best friends, but then they did different sports and they kind of drifted apart. And my boy was just really, really hurt by this. And then time went on a couple of years and they started doing the same sport again. and they reconnected. So if it was a good friendship once,
现在正是授粉季，而我的业务正在快速增长。
chances are it may rekindle. It's peak pollination season, and my business is scaling fast. To keep the nectar flowing, I need a phone plan with top priority data speeds. That's why I chose GoogleFi Wireless. My connections stay strong even when the hive is buzzing. Plus, unlimited plans started $35 a month.
如果你发现迹象表明你的孩子是对其他孩子刻薄或排挤其他孩子的人，你该如何处理？
Now, that's a deal that doesn't stay. Explore GoogleFi Wireless plans today. plus taxes and government fees. GoogleFi wireless is not subject to data traffic deprioritization during times of high network usage. What if you discover, you see signs maybe, that your child is the one who is being mean to other kids or excluding other children? How do you deal with that? Oh, that feels awful, doesn't it? As a parent and is like, oh my gosh, what did I do?
但让我告诉你一项有趣的研究。
How did I fail that this kid would do something mean to somebody else? But let me tell you an interesting study. The researchers got teachers to identify the kids who were especially aggressive or especially non-aggressive. And these were elementary age kids. And then they video recorded the kids on the playground. Like, I don't know how they got permission to do this, but they did. What they found was that those especially aggressive kids did some kind of mean behavior
这不是件好事，但它也有点像婴儿为了看会发生什么而把勺子从高脚椅上扔下去一样，对吧？
every two minutes. But those especially non-aggressive kids, they did some kind of mean behavior every three minutes, right? So this is common. Children's empathy is not fully developed. They're not that good at imagining other people's perspective. They will get better with time. If we think of ourselves, we are more empathic at age 29 than we were at 19 than we were at 9. You know, just more experience in the world gives us a greater capacity to empathize with others. And the little frontal low grows in, too, so that helps. So it is normal that kids will make mistakes about getting along with people. And they also, so their empathy is in fully developed and they experiment with social power. That's not nice, but it's also kind of like the baby throwing the spoon off the
儿童不是通过受苦来学习，而是通过做正确的事情来学习。
high chair just to see what happens, right? They're experimenting. What we don't want to do is say, you're bad and you're a bully and so forth. Just labeling the kid is bad is not useful. One of the principles that I use in my practice is that we can't help a child move forward by convincing them of their badness, right? And when we're angry, that's often what we tend to be drawn to do. It's like, you keep doing these mean things. If you get up like keep on like this, you're going to end up like that. None of that is helpful because it applies that the next chapter of the story is more meanness. Children learn. We also don't want to, you know, like blast them with a punishment because children learn not through suffering, but by doing it right. So that's what we need to figure out is how can we get this
所以我开发的一项技术，可能是我发明过的最好的东西，因为它行之有效，而且对孩子管用、对配偶管用、对同事也管用，它被称为“温和的批评”。
kid back on track with being a kind child? So one technique that I developed, which is probably the best thing I ever invented because it works and it works with children, it works with spouses, it works with co-workers, and it's called a soft criticism. Now, the normal response to criticism is to defend. Well, it's not my fault and you do it too and they do it more. So the soft criticism is designed to get around that normal defensiveness. And we start, step one, step one, by giving an excuse. The excuse says to the child that we know they're a good person with good intentions, even when they mess up.
所以你可能会说这样的话：我知道你不是故意的。
Also, in order to think of an excuse, we have to stop, imagine their perspective that raises our empathy, lowers our anger, great place to start. Plus, just at a practical level, if we give them an excuse, they don't have to come up with one, and we can just kind of step over that. So you might say something like, I know you didn't mean to. You probably didn't realize. I get that you were trying to, whatever it was. Then step two is the part we want, which is describe the problem.
所以你可以说：当你在争吵时，坏行为会导致坏结果。
And here what you want to say is when you, bad behavior, bad outcome. So an example might be, I get that you were really frustrated that that girl was saying that you couldn't sit at the table. And that was a mean thing to do. And you were really upset. At the same time, when you shove her out of her chair, you could really hurt her. And you're the one who ended up in trouble. And then the third step, which is the most important step, is we talk about moving forward.
研究告诉我们，倾向于攻击性行为的孩子，不同研究显示他们有两个特征。
So you might say, what can you do to help her feel better? or what could you do instead if that happens again? Or who do you think could help in this situation? So we're helping the child to think through options. Research tells us that kids who tend to be aggressive, there are two characteristics from different studies. One of them is that they tend to assume that other people are doing things out of deliberate meanness. And what I do in my practice is I talk about,
也许他只是借了一秒钟。
the maybe game. So maybe they're doing it out of deliberate meanness because they want you to suffer, but probably not. Deliberate meanness, you know, real intentional cruelty is pretty rare. So what are some other reasons why they might have been doing that? And if we can get the child to think of other possibilities, it makes the deliberate meanness explanation less likely. So, for example, Jeffrey took your pencil. Now, maybe he did it out of deliberate meanness because he wanted you to suffer. But probably not. What are some other possibilities?
但孩子们在情绪非常激动时，我们只需要共情、共情、再共情。
Maybe he just borrowed it for a second. Maybe he took it without realizing. Maybe he thought it was his pencil. Maybe it actually was his pencil. They wouldn't come up with that one. And then the other thing that these aggressive kids struggle with is they don't know any other options. So when we as parents can slow things down, in a calm moment, not when they're very heated, when they're very heated, we just empathize, empathize, empathize.
如果你有一个非常害羞的孩子，你觉得你的孩子就是交不到朋友，你很担心，你觉得她很不快乐，你应该怎么办？
But in a calm moment, help them to think of other options or my favorite question, what can you do to help that person feel better? And then we get them back on track of being a good kid. What should you do if you have a very shy child and you feel like your kid just isn't making friends and you're worried and you think she's just really unhappy. Or maybe she's not. Maybe she seems fine, but she doesn't have friends. What should you as a parent do?
我们必须牢记的另一件事是，社交的方式有很多种。
Be careful about labeling the child is shy because that makes it sound like it's something inherent and unchangeable. So you might use language like it takes you a little while to get comfortable in a new situation or you like to watch first before you dive in. The other thing we have to keep in mind is that there are. are many ways to be social. And not everybody has to be bounding into the room, life of the party, extrovert, right? There is certainly room in the world for a quieter way of interacting. We want to work with rather than against our child's natural tendencies. So this might be
然后你打招呼，并说出这个人的名字，因为这会让问候变得很私人。
by choosing activities that fit this child's interests. And then it's very easy for them, or it's easier for the child because the conversation comes naturally from whatever the activity is, and that could be a way in. Sometimes we want to help them learn specific skills, like how to give a friendly greeting. I talk about four steps in this. So you smile to show that you're happy to see the person, you look them in the eye, or if that's uncomfortable, you look them in the forehead. If you look people in the forehead right between the eyebrows. From a little bit of a distance, it looks the same as looking them in the eyes. So that can be a way for kids who are uncomfortable with eye contact to do that.
焦虑的孩子在同龄人面前往往会低头并移开视线。
Then you say hi and you say the person's name because that makes the greeting personal. It's like I'm happy to see you. Now, some kids will resist this. I don't want to do that. It's weird. So with those kids, I start a step back and say, okay, tomorrow when you go into school, I just want you to count how many greetings you see. And what they come back with is a million, right?
还有来自研究的关于如何加入群体的另一件事。
And they come to see that that is the expected behavior. That is the typical behavior. So they're actually standing out by not greeting people. Kids who feel anxious around their peers tend to look down and look away. And they're focused on their own distress. But the message that they're sending to other kids is, I don't like you and I don't want anything to do with you. That's not how they feel, but that's where they're communicating. So with these children, we can help them role-play greetings until they feel comfortable doing them.
考虑一下，从孩子的角度来看，走过去说，嗨，我是萨拉，我也能一起玩吗？
And then maybe even set a goal of greet however many people each day. And little by little, they will become more comfortable with it. There was another study that I read that was talking about socially anxious children. and they found that there were two main groups. One group of these anxious kids withdrew and stayed by themselves. The other group was equally anxious, but they were in the mix of things, and they just kind of smiled and nodded. And long term, those kids did just fine. So with some of my clients, I'll say, all you have to do is smile and nod.
这听起来也是应对鸡尾酒会的好建议。
Sometimes you can help them to just learn some tips about how to have a conversation. You can enter a group with a compliment, a sincere compliment. It's like a little gift, and it tells the person, I like you. Also, we tend to like people who appreciate our finer qualities, right? So it makes them like you a little bit better also. or there's another thing from research about how to join a group. We adults tend to tell the kids, go over there and introduce yourself and ask if you can play. No, this is not what happens on the playground.
有时候，你可以帮他们学到一些关于如何进行对话的小技巧。你可以带着赞美加入一个群体，真诚的赞美。这就像一个小礼物，它告诉对方，我喜欢你。而且，我们往往会喜欢那些欣赏我们优秀品质的人，对吧？所以这也让他们更喜欢你一点。或者研究中还有关于如何加入群体的另一种方法。我们成年人往往会告诉孩子，去那边自我介绍，然后问能不能一起玩。不，操场上可不是这样的。
So what they need to do is a sequence that I call watch, then blend. So watch what the other kids are doing and then slide into the action without interrupting it, without drawing attention to yourself. Think about it. From a kid's perspective, going over there and saying, hi, I'm Sarah, can I play too? Is rude because it stops the play. Everybody else has to turn around,
所以他们需要做的是我称之为“观察，然后融入”的流程。即观察其他孩子在做什么，然后悄悄加入活动，不要打断，也不要引人注目。想想看。从孩子的角度来看，走过去说，嗨，我是莎拉，我也能一起玩吗？是很粗鲁的，因为这会停止游戏。其他人不得不转过身来，
look at your kid, decide if they want her to play. And that's just too much of an opening for the mischievous kids who are going to say, no, you can't play. So that's not ideal. So instead, they can join by either giving a compliment, or just trying to slide into the action and do what everybody else is doing. So look around, see what they're doing.
看着你的孩子，决定是否让她加入。对于那些调皮的、会说“不，你不能玩”的孩子来说，这给了他们太多拒绝的机会。所以这并不理想。相反，他们可以通过赞美，或者只是试图融入活动并做其他人正在做的事情来加入。所以环顾四周，看看他们在做什么。
Do that. Do that. Sounds like good advice for navigating a cocktail party too. Exactly. Well, the same principle applies to older kids and teens and adults. And here, the Watch Them Blent sequence is about matching the emotional tone of the group. So if everybody is talking about the latest collectible and our boy comes over and says, well, these are stupid, I mean, they're just cardboard with pictures printed on them. That's like a sour note in a melody.
照着做。照着做。听起来这也是应对鸡尾酒会的好建议。没错。同样的原则也适用于较大的孩子、青少年和成年人。在这里，“观察然后融入”的流程是关于匹配群体的基调。所以如果每个人都在谈论最新的收藏品，而我们的男孩走过来却说，嗯，这些太蠢了，我的意思是，它们只上面印着图案的纸板。这就像是一曲美妙旋律中的不和谐音符。
La la la la. Right. So, and he may as well have a sign above his head saying, I don't belong here. So we don't want that. He can either ask an interested question, starting with how or what, of what? why, because that can sound very judgmental. Like, why did you do such a thing? Or he can, yeah, so ask an interested question or just give a compliment and or make a comment about the thing that matches the tone. If everybody's enthusiastic, he has to be enthusiastic. Or he has to
啦啦啦啦。对。所以，他头上差不多就像顶着一块牌子，上面写着“我不属于这里”。所以我们不希望这样。他可以问一个感兴趣的问题，以“怎么”或“什么”开头——什么？为什么？因为那听起来可能会很有评判性。比如，你为什么要这样做？或者他可以，对，所以问一个感兴趣的问题，或者只是赞美一下，或者对符合语调的事情发表评论。如果所有人都很热情，他也必须热情。或者他必须
find a group where they all hate the collectibles and that's fine too. Or another example is if everybody's complaining about the social studies test and our girl comes in and says, well, I thought it was easy. Oof. You know, sour note there. Now, she doesn't have to lie and pretend that she's stupid. Like deceit is not a path towards intimacy. But what she could do is match the tone and say, yeah, I can't believe there were four
找一个大家都讨厌收藏品的小组，那也行。另一个例子是，如果所有人都在抱怨社会学考试，然后我们有个女孩走进来，说，噢，我觉得挺简单的。哎呀。你知道，这很不和谐。现在，她不需要撒谎，假装自己很笨。因为虚伪不是通往亲密关系的途径。但她可以做的是配合语调，说，对啊，真不敢相信竟然有四个
short answers or it's so unfair that we had the social studies test on the same day that we had the math test or whatever it is. And that she's matching the tone of the group. Now, do you see the same friendship dynamics at work? in boys and in girls. I mean, as adults, men tend to have fewer close friends than women do. Is that true among children? There is some research about differences between boys and girls' friendships.
简答题，或者同一天既考社会学又考数学太不公平了，诸如此类。她这样就配合了小组成员的语调。现在，你觉得在男孩和女孩身上，能看到相同的友谊动态吗？我是说，作为成年人，男性往往比女性拥有更少的好友。在儿童当中也是如此吗？确实有一些关于男孩和女孩友谊差异的研究。
And anybody who's ever looked at a playground sees the separation at a certain age, and then they come together as they get older towards the teen years. So some people have kind of characterized it as a deficit for boys. that, you know, girls have more intimate friendships. Boys tend to be in larger groups. But the flip side of that is that girls tend to have higher expectations of their friends. So they feel more betrayed when the friend doesn't meet those expectations and isn't there for them the way they think that ought to be. Boys tend to, and again, these are generalizations, but boys tend to be better at stepping past a conflict and keep the
任何观察过操场的人都会发现，到了某个年龄段他们会分开，然后随着年龄增长到青少年时期，他们又会聚在一起。所以有些人把这描述为男孩的劣势，你知道的，女孩有更亲密的友谊。男孩往往在较大的群体中。但硬币的另一面是，女孩往往对朋友有更高的期望。所以当朋友没有达到这些期望、没有像她们认为的那样支持她们时，她们会感到更被背叛。男孩往往——同样，这些都是概括——男孩往往更擅长跨越冲突，让
game going kind of thing. And that is a strength. So there's been mixed results about whether boys or girls have more conflicts. And I think they're about even as my read on things. Now, you host a podcast for kids, right, called Dr. Frentastic, great name, where you answer questions directly from children. Do you have any favorite questions and answers you could tell us about? Sure, yes. So this is probably my favorite work activity. So the podcast comes out weekly and it's just five minutes. And every episode features an audio recording of a question about friendship from a child. And the kids' questions are deep. I just love them. So one of them that came up recently, there was a little eight-year-old girl named Vera. And she sent in a question. asking, do we have to change ourselves to make friends? Like, how cool is that? Oh, my gosh, I couldn't wait to answer it.
游戏继续进行。这是一种优势。因此，关于男孩还是女孩经历更多冲突，研究结果褒贬不一。我认为按我的理解，两者差不多。现在，你主持一个面向儿童的播客，对吧，叫《Dr. Frentastic》（疯狂医生），名字很好听，你在节目中直接回答孩子们的提问。你有没有特别喜欢的问答可以跟我们分享？当然有。这大概是我最喜欢的工作内容了。所以这个播客是每周更新的，只有五分钟。每集都会播放一段孩子们关于友谊提问的录音。孩子们的问题很深刻。我太喜欢了。所以最近有一个问题，有一个八岁的小女孩叫维拉。
So my answer was that my favorite questions in life, not just on the podcast, are ones where it looks simple on the surface, but the more you think about it, the more questions it raises. So what do you mean by change? What do you mean by self? What do you mean by friends? So this is just delicious. And I went through all of those, and I talked about how we are all different in different situations, different relationships, and we also change over time.
她发来一个问题，问，为了交朋友，我们必须改变自己吗？天哪，这个问题多棒啊！噢，天哪，我迫不及待地想回答它。
At the same time, we do have a sense of authenticity, of moments where we think, this is who I am or want to be. And that's beautiful. That's beautiful. But we also will sometimes do what a friend wants, even if it's not exactly what we're not exactly. what we want. But this is very authentic because it taps into our deepest values of caring for the friend. So the answer to the question, do we need to change ourselves to make friends, is no. We need to show up as our most authentic caring selves. But I love the intellectual challenge of can I say something meaningful and practical in five minutes. And just the, the children, voices are delicious and their questions are really, really wonderful. Some of them are very specific
所以我的回答是，我生活中最喜欢的问题——不仅是在播客里——往往是那些表面看起来很简单，但你越思考，引发的问题就越多的问题。你所说的“改变”是什么意思？你所说的“自我”是什么意思？你所说的“朋友”是什么意思？所以这真的很有意思。我把这些都过了一遍，我谈到了我们在不同的情境和关系中是如何表现得不同的，而且我们也会随着时间而改变。
to kids. So I had a little boy who called in or sent in our recording saying that somebody had punched his example owl. Oh my goodness. Yeah. But some of the issues are just things that we as adults are continuing to grapple with. So I had a little girl who sent in a question about a friend breaking off the friendship because of just one little thing. And I got to talk about perspective taking that sometimes what feels small to us might feel big to her. And another kid wrote in about a friend lying to them. And then I was able to talk about, well, yes, lying is bad. But do you make it easy for your child to, for your child.
与此同时，我们确实有一种真实感，在某些时刻我们会觉得，这就是我，或者这就是我想成为的我。这很美好。这真的很美好。但有时我们也会做朋友想做的事，即使那不完全是我们想要的，甚至完全不是我们想要的。但这非常真实，因为它触及了我们关爱朋友的最深层价值观。所以对于“我们是否需要改变自己来交朋友”这个问题，答案是：不需要。我们需要以最真实、最具关爱精神的自我出现。但我很喜欢这种智力挑战：我能不能在五分钟内说出有意义且实用的话。而且孩子们的声音本身就很美妙，他们的问题真的非常非常棒。其中有些问题非常具体
for your friend to tell the truth to you. So I'm always pushing for empathy and reflection and what can you do, you know. So I wrote an article once about the limits of hashtag mental health, right? And like I've written 10 books. I've done dozens of videos and I don't know how many articles. But so I believe deeply in giving psychology away. But what I don't like is a lot of times, hashtag mental health, is about pointing out how somebody else is bad. That's not useful.
针对小孩子。我有个小男孩打电话来或者发来录音，说有人打了他的示例猫头鹰。哦天哪。是的。但有些问题也是我们作为成年人一直在努力应对的事情。我有个小女孩发来一个问题，关于一个朋友因为一件小事就跟她绝交了。我就有机会谈谈换位思考，有时候对我们来说很小的事，对她来说可能很大。另一个孩子写信来问关于朋友对他们撒谎的事。然后我就能讨论，嗯，是的，撒谎是不对的。但是你有没有让你的孩子，不对，你的孩子……
In therapy, if you are talking about somebody else's foibles, you're not doing therapy because that person is not in the room, right? We can't control them. We can only control what you do, how you think about the situation, how you respond to the situation, the choices that you make. So last question, we've just hit the four-year anniversary of the COVID pandemic. It's been a lot written early on about how COVID isolation could affect kids' development and their friendships. So four years out, do you think we're still seeing effects from the pandemic? I do. And I don't have data on that, but my teacher colleagues tell me that children are less able to deal with conflict and less willing to reach out.
你的朋友更容易对你讲实话呢？所以我总是呼吁同理心、反思以及你能做些什么，你知道的。所以我曾经写过一篇文章，探讨“标签式心理学”的局限性，对吧？就像我写过10本书。我做过几十个视频，写过多少文章我都不记得了。所以我坚信要将心理学知识普及出去。但我不喜欢的是，很多时候，“标签式心理学”都在于指出别人的不对。这毫无用处。
Oh my gosh, I have to pressure my clients to say get together in person because they're used to, too used to staying apart. So I think that that is really, really important. This finger pointing, I don't know if it's the pandemic or it's the times we live in, but I think that that is really unhelpful. For instance, I,
在治疗中，如果你一直在谈论别人的小毛病，你其实并没有在做治疗，因为那个人不在房间里，对吧？我们无法控制他们。我们只能控制你的所作所为、你如何看待这种情况、你如何应对这种情况，以及你所做出的选择。那么最后一个问题，我们刚刚迎来了新冠疫情爆发的四周年。早期有很多关于新冠疫情期间的隔离如何影响儿童发育和友谊的文章。所以在四年后的今天，你认为我们仍然能看到疫情带来的影响吗？我认为是的。我虽然没有相关数据，但我的教师同事告诉我，孩子们处理冲突的能力变差了，也更不愿意主动沟通了。
think the word bullying is thrown around way too easily. And as a clinical psychologist, I have seen the very serious cases of peer abuse. So like that is very difficult and very important. But what I've seen a lot more often is what I call ordinary meanness. And this is just clumsy efforts to handle a conflict. For instance, I had a young girl who was very upset because her friend was sitting with someone else on the bus. And so she decided to write a long letter to the friend, listing everything that the friend had ever done because she was convinced that this friend was bullying her by excluding her. The friend got the letter and accused my client of bullying her because the what was really mean.
天哪，我不得不向我的客户施压，让他们聚在一起，因为他们太习惯、太习惯彼此隔离了。所以我认为这真的非常非常重要。这种指责别人，我不知道是因为疫情还是因为我们生活的时代，但我认为这真的毫无帮助。例如，我……
But there was no bullying on either side. It was just really a clumsy effort to resolve a conflict. It was hurt feelings and just not knowing how to get past that friendship rough spot. So I don't believe in trying to separate the good kids from the bad kids because we all make mistakes. But I believe in helping kids learn to speak up in kind. ways to forgive their friends. In one of my books, Growing Friendships, I talk about forgiveness guidelines. I had a client once who, it was the mom and the kid and I were talking about who could he get together with. And the mom said, well, how about the boy down the street?
觉得“霸凌”这个词被用得太滥了。作为一名临床心理学家，我见过非常严重的同伴虐待案例。所以这非常困难，也非常重要。但我更常见到的是我所说的“普通的刻薄”。这只是处理冲突时笨拙的尝试。例如，我有一个年轻女孩非常沮丧，因为她的朋友在公交车上和别人坐在一起。于是她决定给那个朋友写一封长信，列出了那个朋友做过的所有事情，因为她确信这个朋友通过孤立她来霸凌她。那个朋友收到信后，指责我的客户霸凌她，因为这封信真的很刻薄。
And the kid responded, no, because two years ago in travel soccer, he never passed the ball. Do you think that other kid remembers that? Absolutely not. So the forgiveness. guidelines are things like, if it wasn't that big of a deal, let it go. If it happened once and it's never likely to happen again, let it go. If the person is genuinely sorry for it, let it go. If it happened more than a month ago, definitely let it go. We don't want to be holding onto grievances like beads on a string. This is part of being a good friend, is opening our hearts to forgiveness. There's another thing that I see a lot, which is anxiety about friendship. And what happens is the kids will seek reassurance, right? We know that that's one of the characteristics
但双方都没有霸凌。这只是一种试图解决冲突的笨拙尝试。那是受伤的情绪，只是不知道如何度过友谊的摩擦期。所以我不相信试图把好孩子和坏孩子区分开来，因为我们都会犯错。但我相信要帮助孩子们学会用善良的方式大声表达，去原谅他们的朋友。在我的其中一本书《Growing Friendships》（培养友谊）中，我谈到了原谅的准则。我曾有一个客户，当时是妈妈、孩子和我一起讨论他可以跟谁一起玩。妈妈说，那街那头的那个男孩怎么样？
of anxiety is constantly seeking reassurance to try to make the anxiety go away. But it actually raises the anxiety because as soon as you get the reassurance, the worry pops up again because what if, what if, what if? So what it might look like with kids is one girl says to another girl, are you mad at me? And she says, no. Are you sure you're not mad at me? No. Really, are you absolutely positive you're not mad at me? And now I am. A friend is like, oh, I wasn't. So it's actually a gift that we give our friends by giving them our trust that even if we're not together and even if we haven't spoken in a little while, there's still a connection. There's still a liking. that can be a hard thing to do.
那孩子回答说，不行，因为两年前在旅行足球队里，他从来不传球。你觉得另一个孩子还记得这事吗？绝对不记得。所以原谅的准则比如：如果这不是什么大不了的事，那就放下吧。如果事情只发生了一次，而且以后不太可能再发生，那就放下吧。如果对方真心感到抱歉，那就放下吧。如果事情是一个多月前发生的，那就坚决放下吧。我们不想像穿珠子一样一直抓着旧怨不放。这是一个好朋友的表现，我们要向原谅敞开心扉。还有一件事我经常看到，那就是对友谊的焦虑。会出现什么情况呢？孩子们会寻求保证，对吧？我们知道这是焦虑的特征之一
Well, Dr. Kennedy Moore, I want to thank you for joining me today. This has been very edifying, I think, to everyone, not just kids and parents, but to all listeners. We should all be paying attention to do your advice. Good. Yeah, and I do have a book that was published by Imagination Press. Is that moody, moody, moody cars? Yes. It is, yes.
就是不断寻求保证，试图让焦虑消失。但这实际上反而增加了焦虑，因为一旦你得到了保证，担忧又会冒出来，因为“万一……万一……万一……”呢？所以在孩子身上表现出来的可能是这样的：一个女孩对另一个女孩说，“你生我的气了吗？”对方说“没有”。“你确定你没生我的气吗？”“没有。”“真的吗？你绝对百分之百确定你没生我的气吗？”“现在我生气了。”朋友就会想，噢，我刚才本来没生气的。所以，当我们给予朋友信任时，即使我们没有腻在一起，即使我们有一小段时间没说话，我们之间依然有联系，依然有好感，这也是我们送给朋友的一份礼物。但这可能是一件很难做到的事。
So this is for the little ones, four to eight. And this one, I partnered with Michael Furman. who takes these gorgeous photos of vintage cars. And to me, they look like they have faces and expressive faces. So the text goes freewheeling, full of feeling, traveling near and far. Hong, if you see me, I'm a moody, movie car. So it's very fun. And research tells us that when children at five years old,
好的，肯尼迪·摩尔博士，我要感谢你今天能来参加节目。我想这对每个人来说都非常受益，不仅对孩子和家长，对所有听众都是如此。我们都应该注意并践行你的建议。太好了。是的，我确实有一本由Imagination Press出版的书。是那本《Moody, Moody, Moody Cars》（情绪多变的汽车）吗？是的，没错。
if they are better at recognizing emotions, then four years later, they're better at, better socially and emotionally. they're functioning. So this is, this is important. It's the foundation is giving kids a glimpse into that emotional world. And my most recent book is Growing Feelings, which talks about children's feelings about friends, because where do the big feelings come up, right? In friendships, it's not usually just in the abstract. It's because of our relationships. So this one talks about how to understand and cope with and communicate about our feelings in ways that, strong and caring relationships.
所以这本书是写给四到八岁的小朋友的。在这本书中，我与迈克尔·弗尔曼（Michael Furman）合作，他拍摄了这些精美的老爷车照片。在我看来，它们看起来像是有脸，而且是有表现力的脸。所以书里的文字是：自由驰骋，充满感情，近处远方尽情旅行。如果你看到我，按一下喇叭，我是辆情绪多变的汽车。所以这非常有趣。研究告诉我们，当五岁的孩子
Well, again, thank you so much. This has been very, very interesting and a lot of fun to talk to you. My pleasure. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at www. www.org or on Apple, Spotify, YouTube, or wherever you get your podcasts. And if you like what you've heard, subscribe and please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org.
如果他们更擅长识别情绪，那么四年后，他们在社交和情绪功能方面就会表现得更好。所以这很重要。其基础就是让孩子们得以窥探那个情绪世界。而我最近的一本书是《Growing Feelings》（成长的感觉），它探讨了孩子们对朋友的感受，因为强烈的情感通常在哪里出现呢？在友谊中，它通常不仅仅是抽象的，而是因为我们的关系。所以这本书探讨了如何以能够建立强大且关爱关系的方式去理解、应对和沟通我们的感情。
Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Condayan. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
好的，再次非常感谢你。这次访谈非常非常有趣，跟你聊得很开心。不用客气。你可以在我们的网站 www.apa.org 上，或者在 Apple、Spotify、YouTube 或任何你获取播客的平台上找到往期的《Speaking of Psychology》（心理学说话）节目。如果你喜欢我们节目的内容，请订阅并给我们留下评价。如果你对未来的播客有任何评论或想法，可以给我们发送电子邮件，邮箱是 speakingofpsychology@apa.org。